few years ago germany decided to phase
out coal as a source of its energy this
decision was driven by the german
environmental movement which was funded
and encouraged by russia which does not
care at all about the environment
certainly not germany's environment but
does want europe to be more dependent on
russian oil and gas
the german government had already gone
cold on nuclear energy years earlier
again thanks to that environmentalist
movement and renewable energy is mostly
a joke so by killing coal germany gave
virtually all of its leverage on energy
away
to putin once putin had all of the
leverage putin invaded ukraine but once
putin invaded ukraine germany was
pressured to stop buying russian gas
now germany still needed the russian gas
so germany is today
trying to restart the coal plants before
the germans freeze to death in the
winter and before european resolve
completely collapses on the sanctions
against russia
which means that europe today is weaker
economically and from a security
standpoint
without any environmental benefit
whatsoever and the craziest part of it
all is
that trump predicted all of it
you know everybody's everybody's talking
about it all over the world they'll say
well wait a minute we're supposed to be
protecting you from russia
but why are you paying billions of
dollars
to russia for energy why are countries
in
nato namely germany having a large
percentage of their energy needs paid
you know to russia and taken care of by
russia now if you look at it
germany is a captive of russia because
they supply they got rid of their coal
plants they got rid of their nuclear
they're getting so much of the oil and
gas from russia i think it's something
that nato has to look at i think it's
very inappropriate you and i agree that
it's inappropriate
that was trump reaming out the nato
secretary general jens stoltenberg back
in
2018 the pain that the west is
experiencing right now
is not a fluke it's not just dumb luck
aw shucks who could have guessed this
this was all clear to everyone with even
a modicum of common sense
the west's enemies are eating our lunch
and we can whine about it and we can cry
about it but we have mostly ourselves or
at the very least our incompetent and
corrupt ruling class to blame i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from timothy brinson
who says joe biden running america is as
easy as riding a bike that's not nice
that's not nice
it's it's pretty accurate it's as easy
as riding a bike you never forget
you never forget how to do it until you
do and then you forget and then
everything falls to pot when things are
collapsing all around you you probably
want to take some plans for your
retirement that's why you got to check
out alto ira right now go to alto ira
michael do you have an account with
coinbase are you thinking of opening one
cryptocurrency may very well represent
the future of money it's one of the most
exciting investment opportunities to
come around for a long time
then you got to wonder
what about taxes when you do anything in
life there's one way to do it and then
there is a uh smarter way to do it so
you might be investing in cryptocurrency
now is a time that actually people are
buying a lot of cryptocurrency because
price is at a spot that is lower than it
has been recently uh so you might be
doing that but did you know that you can
trade bitcoin ethereum and over 80 other
cryptocurrencies in a tax advantaged ira
well with an alto crypto ira you can
trade crypto such as bitcoin and avoid
or defer the taxes get into investing in
crypto do it in a smart way do it with
that tax advantaged retirement account
no setup costs you can do it in just a
few minutes they've got a ton of coins
that you can start trading and you can
open an alto crypto ira account with as
little as 10 bucks go to alto ira.com
michael that's a ltoira.com
michael start investing in
cryptocurrency today alto ira.com
michael
there is one headline that has been
cropping up i i don't know every three
weeks four weeks over the past
several months and the headline is this
vladimir putin dying from cancer
or vladimir putin dying from parkinson's
or vladimir putin very dangerously
gravely ill
irrational
not not making his normal moves or and i
i hate it
i don't i don't hate that vladimir putin
is dying i don't hate i i just i hate
the headline
because
the headline to me
is just the west making excuses
for why
we didn't predict what putin is going to
do
or what actually a lot of conservatives
did predict what putin was going to do a
lot of conservatives said if you give
vladimir putin this oil pipeline
that allows it to bypass ukraine it's
going to invade ukraine that's what the
president of ukraine says for goodness
sakes
and the the ruling class the liberal
ruling class in america and in europe
they said gosh who could have predicted
this i know why it's because putin's
acting completely irrationally it's
because he's got cancer and he's looking
death right in the face no he's not
acting irrationally he's acting very
rationally does vladimir putin have
cancer
maybe i don't know is vladimir putin on
the brink of death
i don't really think so but maybe he is
regardless the man is acting in a very
rational way we're the ones acting
irrationally we in the west from not
america too but germany also the west
broadly
it was irrational for germany to give up
its energy programs it was irrational
for
europe and germany to give vladimir
putin this oil pipeline it has been
irrational to allow environmentalist
groups funded by russia to
convince us to get rid of our nuclear
programs
it is irrational for joe biden right now
to shut down american oil and gas new
american oil and gas leases new american
oil and gas pipelines just so that we
can buy more oil from putin and it when
not from putin from
the iranians or from the venezuelans or
from the saudi arabians for that matter
the saudis who we have a generally
pretty good relationship with relative
to those other guys and even then why
are we buying the oil from them the oil
from them doesn't pollute the
environment but the oil in america does
none of that's irrational
putin trying to take back the old
territory of the soviet union
it's not good but it's perfectly
rational i get why he's doing it
and if the west
had
had taken putin seriously and had taken
geopolitics more seriously than we have
in recent years we probably wouldn't be
in this position
and now when the west gets caught with
his pants down what do they say they say
oh no it's because he's he's just acting
like a madman he's not acting like a
madman we're acting like mad men maybe
we should get our heads screwed on
straight and stop putting our heads in
the sand
and i don't know how many more metaphors
i can mix but start taking this stuff a
little bit more seriously we'd be in
much better shape
gotta stop evading reality do you know
do you know part of the reason why we
can't game out putin or we can't game
out xi jinping or we can't
act like responsible serious people on
the world stage because we can't even
figure out what a woman is and we can't
figure out what a man is and we're
wasting all of our time debating these
stupid things that even a five-year-old
knows that we no longer know the genius
adults running our country no longer
know
this is this is one of the reason that
that we need settled norms
there are many there are many good
things about having settled norms
one of them is
that we don't waste our time
a society that doesn't know
what a man is and what a woman is
cannot advance to more complicated
questions it's sort of like in school
you've got to learn two plus two equals
four
before you can start looking at
trigonometry
or more advanced algebra or calculus
you can't do those things until you
figure out the basics if you're
constantly stuck at the basics of
statecraft of the relationship of the
individual to the state and to each
other you're not going to be able to
advance to more complex questions and
then what's going to happen your enemies
are going to eat your lunch
these questions of norms
are largely why the movie light year
just flopped at the box office over the
weekend which
not to say i told you so but i did
predict that that would happen the the
light year movie is the the latest toy
story movie it's a prequel
and unlike the earlier toy story movies
which generally are good certainly the
first one is terrific i think number two
is good too i don't think i saw number
three or was there a fourth or might
have been a fourth i'd but they
generally they've been good movies and
then this one
they fire tim allen who's the voice of
buzz lightyear and they fire him because
he's a conservative it's
the only reason that makes sense they
didn't fire him because he was too
expensive they hired a more expensive
actor to do it chris evans but chris
evans is a huge lib and tim allen is an
outspoken conservative so they fire tim
allen and then they insist on on
inserting a lesbian kiss scene
they insist and it had initially been
cut but then the gay
organization of disney employees got
very upset that it was cut and so for
pride month and to spite governor ron
desantis they reinserted a lesbian kiss
scene and then a bunch of conservative
parents and normal parents and centrist
parents and center-left parents even
said no
no i don't think so because it's it's
not even just because we don't want to
see lesbian toys kiss
it's because it's not toy story
it's because whatever this thing is i i
know it looks like toy story it's got
the same characters and the same colors
and the same
animation but it's not toy story now
it's there it's the left using toy story
which is a nice wholesome normal story
to push its own woke ideology the box
office estimates
dropped 35
35 in one day
early friday morning heading into the
weekend
the estimated box office was 85 million
dollars domestic
then by the end of the day the estimates
had dropped down to 55 million the
actual close was 51 million the
estimates for the global box office was
135 million
then dropped down to
85.6
million dollars way way down wasn't even
the biggest movie of the weekend so much
money went into this movie so much hype
went into this movie didn't even clear
the biggest movie of the weekend the
biggest movie of the weekend was the new
jurassic park movie which did not open
this past weekend it opened the weekend
previously so the second weekend for
jurassic park was better than the first
weekend for the new toy story movie why
it's obviously just because of this
fight over norms and over the gay kiss
and the liberal actor playing buzz
lightyear and it's because the left has
misunderstood america's penchant for
tolerance
now
when you want to just take the weight of
the world off your shoulders and stop
just being so tense and just lie back
and relax you gotta check out helix
right now go to helixsleep.com
knowles i want to invite you into my
boudoir i'm going to do it in a really
respectful way because i am a married
man but i'm going to describe to you
what it would be like to enter into my
boudoir with helix
you
take a quiz
it takes two minutes to complete matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you why would
you want a mattress made for someone
else why would you want my mattress you
want a mattress like my mattress but you
don't want my specific mattress because
you and i are different helix
understands this they want a mattress
for the way that you sleep they've got
soft medium firm mattresses mattresses
that'll cool you down if you sleep hot
mattresses that are great for spinal
alignment to prevent those morning aches
and pains they've got a helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers they
ship it right to your door for free you
never need to go to the mattress store
again i love these guys i love the
mattress is incredible i love that they
support the show when you are ready to
get your next mattress which could be
right now go to helix these guys are
great they're offering up to 350 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners this is the best offer yet
so hurry on over to helixsleep.com
knowles
americans are very tolerant
but we do not want to normalize
much of the stuff that we tolerate
there's a difference between toleration
and normalization
and the libs are banking on american
tolerance
in their campaign to normalize all sorts
of behaviors but we don't want to
normalize that stuff americans like our
norms
americans are happy to tolerate
people especially on the sex issues
people's eccentric sexual desires and
behaviors
everybody's got a gay cousin or
something and no one really cares right
we all just sort of tolerate it that's
fine okay it's not a big deal
but we don't want
the lgbt
ideology being taught to our kids in
public schools in libraries in the
movies we don't want that we're happy to
tolerate we'll tolerate
the the drag queen at the bar in
greenwich village
we'll tolerate that that exists we don't
really care
we will not allow that behavior to be
normalized we'll tolerate transgenderism
in the sense that
if there's a mentally ill man who thinks
that he's a woman
we're not going to go out of our way to
get in his face and say no you're you're
actually a man
we're not we're not going to do it
if ben you remember ben shapiro went
viral
some years ago because he was on tv and
this transgender dude was just getting
all up in his face and yelling at him
and ben said well what are your what are
your
genetic characteristics sir right he was
being provocative because it was a tv
show but he wasn't he actually wasn't
the one provoking the situation
it was that wasn't an example of ben
being intolerant i'm sure that if ben
has said this himself if he were at a
dinner party and some dude in a dress
asked to be called she he would oblige
in the moment in the dinner party
but what is being asked by
the tv debates over transgenderism and
the the transgender ideology in
classrooms and libraries and movies is
not toleration it's normalization it's
not just hey will you in your charity in
your grace in your politeness
indulge
some delusions of people at a dinner
party will you tolerate this strange
behavior it is the demand that we
actually lie and we actually pretend
that it is normal for a man to think
that he's a woman and that the man
actually is a woman we're not going to
do that okay and i'm not just speaking
for the right-wing conservatives here
america is just not gonna do that and
that's why the buzz lightyear movie is
not making a lot of money and it's why
there's a parents movement in virginia
in florida all around the country and
the democrats are shocked by this
they're shocked because they overplayed
their hand and yet the libs keep pushing
this joe biden
in a
pride month remarks
just came out and he said the ultra maga
people now we're the weird ones
because we're going after mickey mouse
because we don't we don't want lgbt
propaganda in the disney movies
no one knows better than the people in
this room we have a lot more work to do
a lot more work to do i don't have to
tell you about the ultra maga agenda
attacking families and our freedoms 300
discriminatory bills introduced in
states across this country in texas
knocking on front doors to harass and
investigate parents who are raising
transgender children in florida going
after mickey mouse for god's sake
[Music]
that's getting close to home
but think about this
all of you in this room know better than
anyone that these attacks are real and
consequential for real families
ha ha ha ha they're going after mickey
mouse for yeah because mickey mouse
isn't mickey mouse anymore
just like buzz lightyear is in buzz
lightyear anymore
this is what you're what you might you
might look like mickey mouse
he might have the
sound of mickey mouse but the things
that mickey is pushing
are radical
leftist propaganda ha ha men could
really be women
little kids should chop off their body
parts
and take puberty blockers oh and that
funny goofy huh no man that's what ar
you're like a weird demon mickey you're
not the real mickey you're some bizarro
world mickey that has been hollowed out
and had the essence of mickey taken out
of it and so
what the left banks on is people's
now generational affection for the
disney characters
which have now been murdered and have
been hollowed out and the leftist
virus has crawled inside and reanimated
it's its corpse and it is just used to
push radicalism that's that's what
disney is is under fire for that's what
florida is pushing back against
florida says don't teach five-year-olds
weird sex stuff
disney says we're gonna put all the
weight of our gigantic
multinational corporation behind
a campaign to undermine the voters of
florida and then florida says no you're
not now we're going to actually take
away some of your tax incentives we're
going to fight back we're not going to
let you do that
and so the white house takes the side of
the big woke crazy multinational
corporation trying to groom the kids
and it's not working desantis is very
popular in florida the politicians
around the country who are taking the
side of parents and opposing the
corporations
are winning and this is great news for
desantis by the way this is real i mean
ron desantis is one of the most talented
young politicians i've ever seen this
guy
somehow is at the center of every
national news story and joe biden
clearly sees him as a threat that's why
that's why the sitting president of the
united states the incumbent who at least
says that he's going to run for
re-election keeps going after desantis
desantis is playing this
very well not only is he doing the right
thing here but politically he's doing
the smart thing
desantis has also just made a very smart
political calculation that not a lot of
people are picking up on desantis just
came out during a
press conference about an infrastructure
plan and decided to talk about the
recent elections
in colombia
and i just want to say for on on behalf
of the people of florida we watched the
election results down in colombia and we
have a lot of great colombian americans
here in our state who were very
concerned about what was going on and i
think the results of that election have
been very very troubling uh for people
that believe in freedom in the western
hemisphere uh to elect a former narco
terrorist and a marxist uh to lead
colombia is going to be disastrous and
so we've stood with the people uh here
in florida that have ties to colombia
we've had a great relationship with
colombia as a state
we were all hoping that the outcome
would be different but we've got a
problem in the western hemisphere with
marxism and totalitarianism
really spreading and we thought you know
25 years ago the cold war and all this
stuff and it just keeps rearing its head
uh so uh we'll continue to stand uh with
the people of florida here who are
passionate about freedom in the western
hemisphere particularly in colombia uh
but but very very disappointing and very
very troubling result in that election
why is the government governor of
florida talking about the colombian
election
florida last time i checked doesn't have
a foreign policy
no it's got a lot of foreigners and then
people who become
become americans but
the foreign policy is conducted by the
federal government not by the state
government
why is ron desantis talking about this
election in
colombia it's because
after the cubans
colombians are becoming one of the most
important
demographic groups for movement from
left to right
democrat to republican
the republicans have have long counted
on the support of cubans
this this is the historically this has
been the one hispanic group that
supports the republicans in large
numbers that's why it's the one hispanic
group that the democrats hate that's why
that's why barack obama while he was
flooding the country with hispanic
illegal aliens decided to make it harder
for cubans to come into america because
he doesn't like those cubans because the
cubans vote for republicans well
colombians after the cubans are an
important group of hispanics that have
moved
huge i mean hispanics broadly have moved
to the right in over the last three
years but colombians in particular have
done that and colombians are an
important constituency in florida and
colombians still are paying attention to
what's going on in their old country and
desantis is signaling to them i stand
with you guys i stand against the
radical leftist colombians who are still
back there in that country who just
elected a marxist the reason this
matters is it shows you that while
desantis gets the issues
right and he's able to play the media
very well he he's
he is focused on the minutia on the
nitty-gritty of going into these
individual groups and winning them over
just as desantis has i think done a very
very good job of winning over important
constituencies in the conservative
movement groups in the media groups in
the think tanks ron desantis has
systematically gone in and won those
groups over so too he's doing that down
to the ethnic groups down to the
geographic groups down to it's it's
it shows you that this is a calculated
politician and that's if the other
candidates who are looking at 2024
including donald trump for that matter
if if they want to stop the desantis
momentum they've got to get that
granular too they've because this guy
every day this guy wakes up and he says
what can i do today that will put me
closer to the 2024 republican nomination
and
so far
he's done a very good job of putting
himself in that position
now when we want to fight back on the
culture when we want to settle all sorts
of norms okay how do we do it we don't
just criticize the culture we got and we
make the culture we go out and make
movies one of the great movies we've
made recently is what is a woman by matt
walsh if you want to
watch that movie and others head on over
to dailywire.com subscribe
you go to dailywire.com subscribe and i
would recommend you use code knowles if
you use code knowles you know you might
get a little bonus in there you might be
able to save some money and it's very
important we need you
to help us you have put your money where
our mouths are i think the daily wire
has done a good job so far i say with no
no false modesty but true humility i
think we've done
a decent job so far i think we've really
made a difference in the culture we need
your support to continue doing that and
we will keep we will keep producing
content that i think moves the needle
forward we'll be right back with a lot
more
i'm so sorry it has just come to my
attention that i forgot to wish you all
a happy junty first
it it is junete first today we are
observing the holiday yesterday was
juneteenth
i also didn't mention june 20th and then
of course juneteeth was the day that the
federal government has decided that we
would celebrate juneteenth which is now
a federal holiday it occurred the day
before on a sunday and so juneteenth was
observed on monday june 20th and we are
now discussing it here on tuesday june
21st and uh if depending on how you
react to this segment i might be able to
answer more of your questions tomorrow
on
june 2nd
june 2nd before june 23rd and june 24th
i know
i know that republicans want to embrace
juneteenth there are many republicans
who are embracing juneteenth you know
that really sacred feast day that no one
had heard about until five minutes ago
when the libs invented it and they want
to republicans want to embrace
juneteenth
because one it's supposed to be about
freeing the slaves republican the
republican party freed the slaves
and two we just don't want to be called
racist we are called racist all the time
unjustly by the dems and it bothers us
even when we say that it doesn't bother
us and we want any opportunity to show
the libs that were actually democrats
are the real racists and we're not
racist and but it's just
juneteenth is just
a bad idea
it's a dumb holiday and the only point
of juneteenth
is to
make slavery
to put slavery more at the center of the
american story to emphasize the role of
slavery in america and crucially to
emphasize the importance of the legacy
of slavery when crafting all of our
future policies that the holiday is not
about celebrating america for abolishing
slavery because it theoretically could
be about that if you had a holiday just
to celebrate emancipation then you could
say well yeah it's about how great
america is for abolishing slavery but
that's not what it's about did you
google juneteenth on juneteenth i did i
googled juneteenth and there was a a new
doodle or a new animation on google
there was all sorts of african flags
the kind of african black nationalist
flag the red and the green and the black
and it was there and that those were all
the colors that you saw on the image
search on the page itself
wasn't a lot of american flags
it wasn't
why why is it that juneteenth
was pushed by the libs
some conservatives acquiesced to it but
it's not like this was a movement that
came out of the conservative side of the
aisle or the republican party it was
pushed by the libs and the libs are the
ones that celebrate it why because
the point of the holiday is to
say that america is all about slavery
slavery
not only was not unique to america
but
it's not not even particularly
distinctive
to him
every
i don't need to tell you this i've said
it many times but every country in the
history of the world has had slavery at
some point many countries still do what
makes the west unique is that
we abolished slavery slavery still
exists in africa it still exists in asia
still exists in certain indigenous
cultures
and yet
we the the left in this country which
hates america tries to make the whole
tries to make slavery the entire
american story so i just think it's a
bad idea it's also historically a sort
of dumb day to celebrate the end of
slavery because it doesn't mark the end
of slavery slavery you could say slavery
ends with the emancipation proclamation
that happened before juneteenth long
before juneteenth you could say slavery
really officially ends with the passage
of the 13th amendment that happens after
long after juneteenth juneteenth is just
the day that the mail got to parts of
texas to tell the slaves that they had
been freed prior
has been
in some parts of texas a local tradition
dating back
sometime some
in a lot of the
estate uh decades but you you could say
in parts even earlier than that but the
only reason it's a federal holiday now
is to
dunk on america and make america seem
worse and more evil and say that
america's best days are going to be
ahead of us in the past was awful and
we're a sl enslaving terrible country uh
so i get it i know conservatives want to
enjoy it juneteenth but
it's not there the the
the argue
as i've said i get the argument for
juneteenth because
black people have a unique position in
america in that black people
the ancestors of black people were not
people who chose to come here they were
in large part brought here involuntarily
and i am not one of those conservatives
who says that
you know well that was then this is now
forget about the past let's only focus
on the present and the future there
might be some practical wisdom to that
but also history matters i get it
is there any more conservative point of
view than to observe that history and
tradition and culture and the link
between the generations actually matters
no of course all those things do matter
but
the point of emancipation the point of
the 13th amendment the point of
the
reconstruction era is to say black
people are americans now we have settled
that question and so your independence
day is the same independence day as the
white people it's the same independence
day as everyone else in america it's
it's july 4th that's the day we're going
to celebrate by creating a separate
independence day which is what
juneteenth is the the law creating
juneteenth says it's the juneteenth
national independence day
is to say there's a separate
independence day for black people the
black people are not really americans
we're not all just americans there's
actually a big distinction and we're
never going to come together and we're
never going to be a real country
that's what that's what the left wants
it for and that's a bad idea it's not a
good idea so it's a bad holiday
i much prefer juneteenth and june 21st
and june 2nd speaking of slavery and the
legacy of slavery
ibram x kendi one of the
most successful hustlers huckster con
artists in america who's really enriched
himself on on white guilt and
liberal prattling on about about uh
slavery and legacy of slavery and race
politics ibram kennedy says that the
fight
to free the slaves is being reenacted
today in the fight
to take away your ar-15s
i know you have
a six-year-old daughter so i wonder how
are you going to teach her what this
holiday is
well i'm actually going to teach her
that it's freedom day
and
that throughout this nation's history
there's been two perspectives on freedom
really two fights for freedom
uh enslaved people were fighting for
freedom from slavery
and enslavers were we're fighting for
the freedom to enslave and in many ways
that sort of contrast still exists today
there are people who are fighting for
freedom from assault rifles freedom from
poverty freedom from exploitation and
there are others who are fighting for
freedom to exploit freedom to have guns
freedom to
maintain inequality so i i really want
to get her to understand that there are
multiple
kinds of freedom
and she should be fighting for and
joining with those who are fighting for
freedom from something like slavery
as with almost everything abram candy
says
this is a giant dumb point
a dumb stupid point with a little kernel
of a smart point hidden in there
so the comparison between taking away
people's guns and freeing the slaves is
not only
a silly and absurd comparison but it's
it they're really sort of opposite
points
to have a gun
the whole reason to have a gun right
there in the second amendment
is to protect yourself it is to give
yourself some independence so that you
are not
easily enslaved and controlled
that's that's you it's not to go hunting
it's not to go shooting clay pigeons
it's to protect yourself it's to defend
your freedom even even in that
traditional understanding of freedom
but the this smart point
hidden inside all of kennedy's stupid
demagoguery
is that today the way we talk about
freedom
is very relativistic
the way we talk about freedom
is kind of a zero-sum game when when
some people get freedom other people
lose freedom
and and so freedom is not
reasonable it's not logical it's not
it's not tied to anything in objective
reality it's just about all uh different
competing interests
the interests between the slavers and
the enslaved between the people who want
guns and the people who don't want guns
the people who want i don't know want
drugs and the people who don't want
drugs on the streets that's that's the
way that we do talk about freedom today
it's a stupid view of freedom though
though it is how we talk about it the
freedom of the transgender man i'm sorry
transgender woman to use the women's
bathroom even though he's a dude the
freedom of the transgender man woman to
swim on the girl's swim team even though
he's a dude
necessarily infringes on the freedom of
the women to have their own bathrooms
and locker rooms where they can change
and don't need to have men expose their
genitals to them
or infringes on the freedom of women to
have their own swim teams and swimming
leagues where they can win their own
trophies and win their own scholarships
and not constantly be beaten by men
if there is
if freedom can describe all of those
things then yes those freedoms are in
conflict but that's why
there is no such thing as a freedom
to transgenderism as a right to
transgenderism
the lib understanding of freedom as
being able to do whatever you want to do
and just follow your own desires is
just a false one and you're especially
seeing this here and ibram kendi is
accidentally proving it to you
there's then the conservative
understanding of freedom which is that
freedom
is
not sinning
freedom is doing good freedom is doing
what you're supposed to do the man who
sins is a slave to sin
that liberty i've talked about this on
the show many times that liberty is not
licentiousness that you don't you don't
have a right to do something that is
unreasonable and not to your benefit as
edmund burke says you don't have a right
to pretend to be a woman and go into the
women's bathroom you can't because it
doesn't make any sense because it's not
true because you're not a woman
that's why you can't have a right to
that even if some crazy activist with
all sorts of crazy colored hair and lots
of
lots of piercings or whatever and
mutilated body parts says i have a right
to this well no you're just that's just
a thing you're saying
so you can say you have a right to but
why do you have a right to that
why you there's no explanation but a
right that is inexplicable a right that
can't have some grounding in objective
reality in say the natural law is no
right at all
that's no so if we're gonna if we're
gonna talk about real freedom if we're
gonna talk about real rights we've got
to ground it in reality and that means
we need to
discard
probably 90 percent of these supposed
rights that have cropped up in recent
years and that continue to crop up every
day just like we need to discard 99
of the fake pronouns that have cropped
up in recent years
you can call yourself by those pronouns
yesterday we played a clip
of a woman who calls herself bun refers
to her pronouns as bun bun self bun bun
self and fair self and all sorts of like
just completely made up words
you can say that those are pronouns but
they're not actually pronouns because
pronouns are limited and they
they have something to do with objective
reality
there's a there's a bell curve here for
how to understand all of these problems
in society our rancor over race and sex
our divisions are our seeming inability
to communicate on what constitutes a
right and freedom and how we want to
live and why we can't even decide what a
man or a woman is
here's the bell curve you've you've got
the guy
at the really stupid end of the iq bell
curve
and the guy's drooling and he can barely
get his words out and he says
duh it's because no one believes in god
anymore
it's because we're not going to church
as much right that's
and then you've got the the midwit in
the middle who says well no actually you
know there are all sorts of social
reasons and it's because of advanced
capitalism and because of the the way
that the political economy is shaped in
the blah blah blah blah and then you get
to the high part of the iq bell curve
and you get the really super smart
genius and you know what he says it's
because people don't believe in god
anymore that's it that's that's what it
all comes down to
i don't want to sound like a bible
thumper like i'm preaching i i guess i
am preaching to the choir that's just
what it's all about
all
all political disagreements all human
conflict
comes down to theology and religion why
especially when we're talking about
christianity when we're talking about
certainly what i believe to be true
religion
we're talking about a religion that
worships the logos right the in in the
gospel of john say in the beginning was
the word and the word is
that's a translation of the word logos
the divine logic of the universe
in the beginning was the divine logic of
the universe and the divine logic of the
universe was with god and was god
so this would be different than say
islam
which views
allah as pure will
allah can do whatever allah wants to do
incl allah if he wanted to make his
followers worship idols that would have
a sort of sense in in islam this was the
subject of the regensburg address
wonderful address by pope benedict i
think probably the most important
address of the 21st century
in which he quotes an islamic scholar
ibn hasam
that's a difference with
christianity where
god is logic as well
and therefore
uh
they're they're there
necessarily must be a logical coherence
to god
as and we've got this gallup poll right
now as fewer americans believe in god
than ever before expect society to make
less sense
okay
at this point at this point i'd take an
islamic society
i really don't mean to dis the muslims i
have a great deal of respect for a lot
of religious muslims because
they believe in something and and what
they believe in has a certain coherence
to it certainly a hell of a lot more
coherence than what the liberals are
pushing right now it's just so amazing
to me to hear
from
liberal people liberal atheists who will
say uh how can you believe in god that's
so crazy you can't even see god that's i
don't i don't see physical evidence for
god
and you say well actually there is a lot
of physical evidence and there's lots of
um i said hold on wait you're the people
who believe in transgenderism right
so i get
you won't believe that god exists
without a specific kind of tangible
physical evidence that you're you're
demanding but you will believe that a
giant husky hairy dude is actually a
woman in contradiction of all physical
signs
make that make sense to me you cannot
make that
make sense to
me it is truly shocking to me that
anybody could believe such a thing but
it makes sense because as
as belief in
god goes away
it's going to affect everything in
society
every settled thing the relations
between men and women our understanding
of our rights and where our rights come
from
our
traditions our holidays our feast days
the very language that we use to
communicate notions of good and bad and
right and wrong and true and false all
of that is going to be questioned none
of that can be settled anymore
and so we're going to be debating the
most elementary things in our society
constantly
and we'll have to try to prove it all
through our unfettered reason but the
stock of reason in each man is
relatively small
so when we don't avail ourselves of the
wisdom of the ages and received opinion
then we're going to be trying to
reinvent all the whole world every
single day
meanwhile vladimir putin's going to be
taking all of our energy
or he's going to be rather taking all of
our money by selling us his energy our
you're going to have china taking
huge swaths of our manufacturing and our
intellectual property and advancing on
our interests and we're not going to be
able to do a damn thing about it because
we're going to be here still arguing duh
what's a woman what's a um what is
what's reality
just all these
things that we should have figured out
when we were in kindergarten at the very
latest but but we have not been able to
do that preschool we should have figured
it out there's a video going around from
libs of tiktok our great friends over
there
of a preschool teacher
i guess a man
i think a male preschool teacher who
identifies as a woman
who
came out
came out to his preschool students
as trans
today on the last day i finally decided
to come out to my kids and my kids are
older they're four and five and
the way that he did is just read him a
book about this teddy bear that kind of
comes out as a trans girl
and it's really nice and it's very
simple they understood it right away and
i think what made me cry the most was
that afterwards like
i kind of looked at them and there was
just a silence in the room and i just
thought like oh my god now they see me
as a totally different person and before
this they loved me i was such a you know
one of their favorite teachers and it
felt
so good to have that and i think that's
one of the biggest fears i had is that
as soon as they found out about me they
would lose
all love for me and then one of my kids
breaks the silence and she gets up and
she just is like she just hugs me and
she's just like everyone give rooty a
hug
and they all came and they gave me a hug
and she was just like we love you like
we love you so much
and i'm yeah it made me really emotional
and it was i think one of the biggest
moments in my transition where i truly
felt like
at peace with um
who i am and that like even kids can
understand it and even kids
can accept me and so it doesn't make any
sense when adults can't because if a kid
can why can't a [ __ ] adult understand
and accept
because kids are idiots
that's why
why why can a why can a four-year-old or
a three-year-old
just
unquestioningly believe that i am a
woman
but an adult with developed faculties of
reason and a clearer perception of the
world doesn't understand that because
because the kids are are little tiny
kids
who don't know the difference between
cartoons and reality
because they're they
they they believe this is a family show
and kids listen to it so i don't want to
i don't want to say i want to dispel
some of the illusions of childhood you
know like certain characters and things
but like kids believe in a lot of stuff
that isn't true
okay
that's why and if you find yourself
if you find yourself in a position where
the the
the only people who will
believe your schtick your your
perception of the world
are little tiny kids and people over the
age of four do not then you should
probably reconsider your point of view
furthermore furthermore if if you
need
the affirmation of kids
for your sex life
you should not be around little kids if
you
are breaking down in tears so happy
when you make a sexual confession to to
three and four-year-olds and then they
come up and hug you and that gives you a
feeling of great pleasure
and you're a man who thinks that he is a
woman i think in this case again i don't
really know the details of it
you for sure should not be around kids
ever
at all you should be hundreds of yards
away at any given time
we there was a a clip do you remember
when fox news ran that bizarre
pro trancing the kids segment just
full-throated endorsement of transiting
little tiny kids the other day was very
strange and they haven't answered for it
at all tucker has been great on it
tucker's just
been sort of subtweeting them
docker's just been running
uh segments on why why we should not
trans the kids but anyway fox news ran
this bizarre segment and at the end of
it
the the reporter who was pushing this
stuff he said people only fear what they
don't understand that's what this is
about
which i guess can be true
but people also fear things that they do
understand
i i fear sharks
if i'm in the water and a shark i see a
shark fin i am going to fear that
not because i don't understand the shark
but because i do understand the shark
and i know that that shark wants to eat
me and it is very much the same way with
gender ideology
we don't fear it's not even we hold it
in a program and we want to stop it we
fear what it could do to society we
don't fear it because we just don't
understand it i do understand it in as
much as it can be understood it's the
claim that a man can really be a woman
despite his body because his body has
nothing to do with his soul i i get that
that same heresy has cropped up many
times over the last two thousand years i
i understand that i have a it's not a
phobia it's a very legitimate rational
fear of what that can do to society even
beyond the sex question of screwing up
the kids and and sterilizing them and
ruining their bodies and messing with
their brains it just the very idea that
the physical world has nothing to do
with our true selves
that idea when it has cropped up has has
really threatened civilization
sometimes
we object to things because
we understand them
actually sometimes we need to elevate
our thinking beyond the thinking of
three and four-year-olds
and beyond the same stupid basic
questions that we shouldn't even be
asking in the first place because they
should be settled
and only then can we think about more
advanced things we can take on adult
sort of behaviors and adult debates or
we can keep
pretending that we're five years old and
our enemies are gonna eat our lunch the
choice i suppose is ours i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the ben shapiro show the
washington post accidentally promotes a
pro-life message in an article meant to
rip texas anti-abortion law the navy
pushes alternative pronouns and joe
biden gets ticked when asked about the
joe session that's today on the bench
shapiro shall give it a listen